we're all so excited that um  feige announced that deadpool 3 is going  to be in the mcu  and uh i'm just curious in the last year  or two have you  actually spoken to kevin feige about  domino and deadpool 3  or no um i haven't  you know i i i would love to revive the  role you know i  i think um that was always something you  know  in the world of of what was potentially  going to happen  um but i haven't had any like specific  conversations around it  um but you know i'm i'm interested i  i not only would i love to revive the  role i would love to like figure out a  way to like  make a domino movie or something like  that so  um you know we'll we'll see we'll see  what happens but i i haven't had any  like personal conversations